okay watch
the footwork so i clear the line
but i'm going to come in
not in a little not in the middle
under his centers whom under the center
boom under
oh
my hand is not peeling it off
but it is in place though it's not
waving
then coming here uh turn me
in place ready to catch it
he should land here under me
under me my foot's in his armpit
he goes around you not away from you
that's an escaping person
you can do this one
under me under
because you push him away
you're not getting this down now okay
you're thinking but it's only it's only
12 inches
don't let it down don't let it down
don't let it down don't let it jump
juicy that's with him not even moving
escaping
when you do the last move
you're not pushing they're not doing the
obvious
you see you're not doing the obvious
resist again
you're not gonna get it okay and he
not even make him move escape out from
under pressure you see
around so i can get an attack from this
side
this side not this side this side
then we're going down got that
so i'm here see this joint
i'm going to tap on this
it's already down
[Music]
this this not around and try to do that
inside down
okay so i'm going to round the corner
around the corner with his elbow
[Music]
it's not going to hit a line
and then another knot it's gonna go
i just have to stay up with it
a figure eight
zigzag is down
okay
[Music]
done